the SONA 5 is a hell of a lot of fun and
if you want to find out every rule thing
for yourself you absolutely can if you'd
like to know some of the things we found
out too while playing that might give
you a boost along the way stick with me
for the next few minutes and I'll sort
you out
be sure to subscribe to check out our
other persona tip videos but for now
here's 10 things I wish I knew before
starting persona 5 first up take your
time I know the temptation is strong to
get those pulses knocked over in the
first few days but if you use those
early deadline days to get a jump on
your social links you'll have an easier
time in dungeon as your teammates will
be stronger and you'll be able to do
things like get extra experience or
money depending on what links you're
leveling next up this is especially
important early on be sure to buy SP
items from vending machines I know they
only give you 5 SP per can and that
doesn't seem like very much but if
you're buying them every week from every
machine that offers them as this
scattered around to Tokyo that can add
up to you having enough SP to secure a
route to the treasure in one run of a
palace instead of leaving to go back
home and waste another day on top of
that if you're wondering what health
items are worth it for what price I
generally figured out that if you're
getting 10 HP for a hundred yen at
minimum that's not so bad if the food
item or what-have-you offers a much
better ratio than that then you should
probably pick it up this tends to apply
particularly to seasonal items some
confidence have much more useful
abilities than others so be sure to
check what's coming up in your confidant
tab if you max your teacher color commie
she can occasionally grant you free time
during the day or more time to do things
at night when you'd otherwise be tired
budding up with the semi annoying
Mishima will grant you more experience
in battle and listening to you shaded
speeches makes negotiating with personas
from money or items easier and more
rewarding on top of that you'll always
want to enhance the links of your ki
party as they have essential skills that
make battling much easier while
navigating around the map on your days
away from the palace be sure to hit
square to see where you can find
confidence to visit even when they
haven't
to hang out this view also tells you if
you can rank up with them immediately
should you choose to hang out unless you
have nothing else to do or need to level
one particular social staff avoid
activities like studying or batting that
only rank a single stat you'd be better
off spending time with confidence as you
can often level both your social link as
well as a special stat that is linked to
spending time with the confidante for
example spending time with her
fermi-levels your knowledge of spending
time with your Sheeta and oh yeah level
your charm and a wire levels your
proficiency next up buy and choose the
right gift if you pay attention to your
confidants taste you can offer them a
great gift to get a big bump in your
social link with them once you've got
the money head down to the underground
mall in Shibuya and buy all the gifts
also try to buy every gift you come
across in new locations you encounter I
know it sounds crazy but it's worth it
to have the right gift for the occasions
the game lets you offer one to a
companion you'll also impress them a lot
more if you give them something they're
interested in for example on is crazy
about sweets let you work out the rest
since we're talking about hanging out
with your pals then our right and wrong
dialog choices for when you get the rare
chance to pipe up while chilling with
your confidants so try to tailor your
responses accordingly wherever possible
before you hang out with somebody make
sure you're carrying a persona of the
corresponding Arcana through the person
you're seeing as it will give you an
extra social link boost when you commit
to hanging out on the topic of personas
make sure you're always fusing the
higher the level of your persona the
better the attributes now I know what
it's like to get attached to a certain
persona but as long as you aren't losing
essential skills in your arsenal by
sacrificing your creatures to make
better ones you should always be
updating your personas filling out your
persona Dex also grants you bonuses like
making persona cheaper to summon if
you're desperate for stat boosts make
sure you eat your burgers if you had to
Shibuya and take on the big burger
challenge successfully you'll get a huge
boost in a variety of
spoiler alert with winning this one so
I'll give you a hot second to mute me if
you want to make sure you don't fail
this challenge take it when all your
stats are levels two three and four for
each consecutive challenge up while that
final burger looks terrifying the tummy
ache is well worth it
finally some tips on mementos mementos
is where you grind between palaces but
it's also where you complete your heart
stealing side quests it's pretty massive
with a huge collection of floors to
every level but in my experience it's
not exactly grueling so I'd recommend
heading in on rainy days when the
enemies are tougher wrapper sown is a
more common and the treasure chests are
more plentiful that way you'll get more
experience for your time and better
rewards as always don't go into a palace
or mementos without a lockpick or
several as possible there's nothing more
upsetting than standing lamely beside a
locks chest that you can't open and in
the randomized mementos you won't see it
again it's also a good idea to stack
your request a mementos visit swallows
your whole day so you'll want to
maximize your time there and get a lot
done in one go you also shouldn't find
it anywhere near as draining on your
team HP and SP as palaces can be so you
can knock over a big pile of requests in
one go that is everything I've got to
tell you about but finally persona 5
tells you to take your time on every
loading screen and you should this isn't
a game to knock over or one where you
need to worry too much about getting
everything right hang out with the
confidence you like doing the activities
you enjoy and you'll most likely find
yourself advancing no matter what let us
know if you found these tips useful and
stay tuned to games but for more persona
coverage and all the other gamey things